[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] It's a
strange dream
My name is Naofumi Iwatani I
'm a second-year university student from Yorito
Numazawa  On top of that, pocket money was also provided, and
I didn't
have to work part-time, so I was able to fully enjoy my life in Ota City.
I was just an ordinary, ordinary nerd, what the heck
,
until I picked up this book.
It's like
each of the four heroes uses a
spear as a weapon
.
Is there a story about the main characters of all four?
I say,
where's the cocoa,
what's this, what's this?
I have summoned the city tax hero The
posture is a child The four of us are legendary heroes
This world is now in a crisis
of life and death That's why the
heroes are lending their strength  Please,
well, there are 5 times where
we just talk about it.
It's just a job
, how much of this stone can you
draw?
First of all, I would like you to have an audience with the cherry blossoms of Melromark in our country, and then I would like
to ask you to negotiate the reward after
that.
You came to the
store
feeling  It's a nice wind It
's like a pamphlet for overseas travel It's
impossible, but have you never been out of Japan
?  Is that a hero that has been handed down since ancient
times?I am Merro Marc's special Merlo 32nd lifeLet's
listen to the names of the heroes
[Music]
Beautiful armorI'm a 16-year-old high school
studentI'm Motoyasu Kitamura, a 21-year-old college studentThe
next one is me,
Kawasumitsuki  I'm a 17-year-old high school student.
My name is Naofumi Iwatani, 20 years old, and I'm a college student.
Well, first of all, I have to explain the situation
.
I'm annoyed by his attitude, but to
summarize, I'm in
this
world.There's a prophecy of the weekend.According to it, the lines that will lead the world to destruction will
come one after another.
Gakko Nation has long had a tool called Ryukoku's Hourglass,
so they can tell when it's coming.
The first wave attacked this country before we were summoned.
And the adventurers managed to repel the first wave
The second and third waves became even more powerful The
hourglass continued to drop sand until the waves stopped surging It was
already less than a month before the second wave
We underestimated the waves, but when we
actually witnessed them, we realized
that only the brave men of the municipal government could withstand them.
No, it
's not exactly the same
story as the book I just
read.  It's fine if you make a promise, but I'll work with you as long as it's not a regular schedule
.
Check our status
Uh,
what's your status?
Let's try to do it Koukou 4 a
Level 1 Is
this uneasy
?  So, from now on, I'll set out on an adventure and raise and strengthen the legendary weapons that have been processed.
Anyway, we should improve ourselves We
're just leveling up.
Why is that? Legend has it that each of the legendary weapons has the property of repelling
them, and it is said that reporting them together will hinder growth.
The legendary weapon seems to be translating it into Japanese The
sun is starting to set in. Take a good rest today
.
It seems that a hero has been summoned All sealers in this country are all
right, so the hero of the shield is the
hero of the legend.
Well, it's like
a game,
or
rather, it's not a game, isn't it? It's just like Emerald Online.  It's a game world
Dimension web is
different, isn't it?
I remember reading a light novel, just in case, just to confirm common sense The
person depicted on the 1,000-yen bill is a life 70 Ah,
who was last year's buzzword grand prize bright star you were?  And then the name of the prime minister who took the demolition of Sado 6. It
seems that we came from
different Japans, doesn't
it?  It doesn't match up to this point I mean, ah, is
everyone playing a game that looks just like this world?
Why is it that only I don't know?
There's something wrong,
so Motoya, so brother, teach me with common sense As
far as I know, stickers are the main edible shields
.
What about my mother? The
terrain is almost the same as the one I know. The hunting grounds for each weapon are different, so we won't go to the same place
.
]
Vertically, it's time to block enemy attacks and protect your friends.
Let's do
our best Tomorrow is the beginning of an adventure
Go back to your room and go to sleep today
[Music] Now
that I've started my big adventure
Will these people become our comrades?
As expected, if a situation like this were to occur, it
would be unpopular that there would be zero victims
.  That's right, it's
said that those who joined the company understand this world, according to tradition.
Well, I'm not familiar with them, but
they curry If you have 5 people, share them
Kaa
[music]
3 people evenly
I guess it would be better to open them one by one, but if I force myself to do so, I might get involved in the ceremony.
Is it okay for
this child to go to my own hero-
sama?
Before there is a
chance, Fumidona should invite her favorite companions to replenish her staff.
If the amount is higher than the other heroes, let's do it
.
Oh,
then I'll receive it firmly as it's the preparation money. In
addition, I prepared 800 silver coins for Fumi-sama and 600 for the other people
.
I can't help you, but I can't help you, but I'll gather allies,
so please do your best.
It's
nice to meet you I
'm relieved that you're so
reserved
But it's because of me that you became my friend I have
to protect you absolutely
So let's go
Music]
I got a glimpse of it yesterday, but the closer I look, the more I feel like I'm in another world.
6th c Then
I'll show you to a good shop I know
.
But when I entered the house, I
was introduced to it gradually.
By the way
, he's a special-armed boyfriend, isn't he
?
I wonder if it will get
across
My name is Naofumi Iwatani.
Thank you.
About 250 pieces of silver ash,
iron magic iron magic steel from the left,
the effect of silver is
not approved.
It seems like I've been
ripped off.
I can buy a house, but I can't seem to speak from my
body.It's strange.
Oh my God,
how much is the price and it's 120 silver coins
?  If you grow up, you won't be able to enter,
so I asked how much it would cost to
sell it.
[music]
[applause]
Yes, I
can absorb as much as I want
ran
This is the power of a legendary weapon, isn't it?
I see.
By the way, this orange balloon is going to sell
in Yamago.  That's about the amount,
and it seems that the rest will change as you level up
.
Equip
, you know, if you equip the sea lion with something good, it will become stronger,
right?
Hmmmm, it's
interesting that you didn't pull it out, hero-sama
.
None
is a cheap total How much will
it cost
?  It's okay Doctor, if I become stronger, I can use the loot from defeating monsters to Dawn
.
Thank you for being a brave
new
person Ah, that's right.
It feels like the best part of Saiseikai.
Ah
, please enjoy it
slowly.Hey, the grasslands where we fought today are hearts.Tomorrow, we
'll head to Rapha village ahead of this map.After passing Rafa village,
there's a dungeon for beginners.
Honjo I can't expect much profit, but
I think it's a good place for the hero to raise his level
.
Don't you drink wine?
You're the hero, aren't you? This country is dominated by women
.
I'm thinking of living in the hut early, but is that
okay?  I'll
make up for the
hut someday.
Unusual price of 200 silver
coins 30 coins for 1 night
, 2 meals, 199 coins for 5 meals for 2 meals
.
I
wonder if that's what it feels like to defeat a monster
Today it's like a balloon It's just over
Horror
I really came to another world tan
[music]
Oh, I'm in the way
There won't be any soldiers tomorrow
[Music]
Help me get some food and leave soon
Money and sandals Oh,
it's lame or you just wake up, it's hard.
Oh
[music]
Hey, what the hell are
you all safe now?
Poor adventurer Mine, I'm
stuck, but could you please testify once more?
I managed to escape and stayed at the same
inn by chance.
By the way,
what are you talking about? I'm Messi's wife, sleep in my room after that.
It was given to me as a present
The hero who shielded himself from the taboos that should not have been committed the most in our
country- The sexual assault of a woman in Bellamarque, even if it was done in a store, it would be the death sentence.
'Cause you're telling me I didn't do it If you're going
that far, it
's Shoko Shoko I was searching the room of the hero of
the shield,
yeah  It wasn't like that when I woke up
.
Were you worried?
You misunderstood that if you're a hero, you
'll be forgiven no matter
what you do.  Yo, no,
why are you doing that? Don't say you're
going to be my comrade Papa
car
Okay, I was going to eat first Oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, what did the criminal say?
Even though I only called you the one who said
it, you called me by name when it came to Motoyasu.
What if this wasn't proof?
I don't
think so.It was a mistake to summon me to take a position in cooking.
But I wanted to make things even a little more advantageous for us.
I need it
[music]
I don't care about it anymore, just
return me to the world where I'm in now So let's digest whatever it is, even if it's a new hero
I'm in another world, so I have to feel like this even if I come to another world
Sugou  It's the worst if you don't even try to fulfill your own seat.
It's only possible to summon when all the posture heroes are dead.
What do you think
I'm thinking about in my own way
?  Pollution There is no time to wait until the next
wave  Because you're a brave man who can stand up against
you But your sins are already well known to the public,
and that's your
punishment.
Before
I guess a lot I'm weak I need
time Tan
It
's not like I don't want
it
,
Zena too.  I know it's about a sheet I'm coming
to the
start
Don't die
Virtua
I thought
[music]
tar After
fighting all night, I'm finally at the level
.  Hmmm, okay,
thank you very much,
you're welcome.
By the way, why don't we do business too
? If this guy sells at a
high price, Anzai City
would be good.  I wonder if there's a
deal here, Ogoten, hmm, I wonder if Eita's negotiations have been concluded
.
There's no sin in things like that. Please spread the rumor about me and lumber in the flower bed
.  Music]
[laughter]
[music]
[music] In other
words, if you
use it for a long time, you can transfer the ability even if you transform it vertically
.  Where can I go? It
's a forest right next to Shirou Don't you know?
I'll be your friend, Mr. Hero of Two, thank you so much, so let
's check the details of the contract
first
.  It's a distribution method, so
I'll take the main amount, so I'll take at least 40%. The
rest will be distributed at my discretion
.
If you play an active role, you can
open it.  Come to think of it, I didn't waste my time, but on the
contrary, Juni, the leader,
ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, guh
Bach.
I can't earn money I can't
earn money, so my attack power doesn't go up no
matter how long it takes It's a bad loop Pain
[music]
You seem to be in trouble Go to the
right
Not enough manpower
It's not such an inconvenient thing that is offered by
.  Of course,
if my interest in the hero of the shield is over,
I'll come with you.
Because they can't lie about
why I want a slave, and
they can never cheat on their master. Slaves can be
severely cursed, using a mark that costs their lives.  How about a peeping off-line meeting?
How about
some?
He's
ignorant of humans, but he's just an opinion about humans, but he's also increased the number of human rooms that have parts that differ from
humans.  A master used for each shadow that makes 810 people fight each other I
see in the category  Is it the same or is it the same,
and since demi-humans are considered to be close to monsters, in this usufrucist country,
life is treated as slaves for this reason.
I found the time of the air raid The house I got lost in is a world of fishing
I'm looking for an answer that I can give instructions to
anal
[music]